this week on quadriga the Trump factor
how dangerous is populism the results
from America's first primary election
the Iowa caucuses are in right-wing and
left-wing candidates set the tone an
unexpected triumph for Ted Cruz a narrow
victory for Hillary Clinton but populist
Bernie Sanders and Donald Trump are
still in the race why has the u.s. moved
away from the middle ground and is there
a link between populism in the US and
populism in Europe coming to you from
Berlin quadriga the international debate
your host this week Melinda crane oh and
welcome is the Trump factor really still
in play after Iowa and if so where is it
taking the US political system that's
what we want to talk about today with
three guests who are following events
very closely it's a pleasure to welcome
Arica hammond she's business editor for
the German daily detox item she says if
Trump were to become the Republican
nominee that would be the best thing
that could happen to the Democrats he
has absolutely no chance to become
president Allen Posner is an author and
commentator for the Berlin day lead
event he says thanks to the two-party
system American populace never get into
the White House American populism is fun
European populism is dangerous and Erik
Kirschbaum has worked for Reuters news
agency and is currently a correspondent
for the Los Angeles Times here in Berlin
he says it is an alarming trend when
candidates on the fringes of both
parties do so well but it's still early
days November is far away Erik
Kirschbaum do we really still need to
worry about the Trump factor doesn't
Iowa perhaps signal the beginning of the
end of the Donald show probably but this
is such a crazy election as tough to
make predictions right now he didn't do
as well as expected but on the other
hand he's very popular with people who
don't vote so there's this factor this
big big block of voters out there who
don't usually go to vote but tell their
pollsters going to vote for him so there
could be a lot of disappointing Trump
results but on the other hand he has
nothing to lose it's entertainment
it keeps the network's happy the
networks are happy that he's in the race
he'll probably be around for a while and
that's probably good news for Hillary
Clinton and he's got a great big war
chest as well that doesn't rely on
donors arica Hammond you say Trump would
have no chance in the general election
but many commentators predicted Trump's
demise months ago and were proved wrong
couldn't you be proved wrong with your
prediction of course every prediction
can be proved wrong but I mean the
problem with a trump is that he is
really very very extreme you can't be
even more extreme than he is so when if
he should be the nominee of the
Republicans then every voter in the in
America who is in the middle on all who
was an immigrant who was Muslim who was
a woman who was this piss panic would
vote for Hillary Clinton and not for
Trump and those people have the majority
those who somehow support Trump and his
extreme views about twenty to thirty
percent of the population so the
Republicans would lose for sure if they
nominated Trump and that's what the
establishment of the Republicans know
exactly that's why they are so alarmed
about Trump's success because it's
obvious that he will ruin the party well
what about Ted Cruz and Marco Rubio Alan
Posner they may not be quite as Extreme
as Donald Trump but they have certainly
adopted his anti-immigrant obama bashing
message so are they really any less
populous than from well they're not
really all that much anti-immigrant both
our sons Rubio and Cruz are both sons of
Cuban immigrants they've made the
American dream they may say and there's
some truth to that that you have to you
know the immigration can't go on
indefinitely in order to give those were
there a better chance but the point is
there's also difference between Ted Cruz
who's a bible-thumping evangelical
person who takes about you know takes
the Word of God literally mr. Rubio who
is adopting some of these tactics but in
the moment he becomes the party's
nominee and has to win over all those
people that owe Rica was talking about
then of course he's going to attack to
the
to the middle to the Center the way
every candidate always does are you so
sure about that given the role of
right-wing media now in the American
political landscape they will absolutely
hold him to accountability if he were to
walk back and as you know he has in fact
now denied that he was ever willing to
go for an immigration deal that would
allow illegal immigrants in the US
citizenship he's now denying positions
that he used to espouse that were
moderate yeah this is true this happened
to Romney last time Mitt Romney the
presidential candidate who in his own
home state of Massachusetts where he was
governor implemented a health care
reform which was almost identical to
Obamacare and then opposed Obamacare
when he was president it didn't help him
with the Electra did it so um so you
know I think there's some things that
electorate's are gonna that the
electorate is not going to in spite of
you know right wing media ranting on I
think the electorate wants to see
someone who can tack to the center and
they will that this vote at the center
will excuse the fact that in the
primaries session we say mr. Rubio has
made some pretty extreme right-wing send
statements that that'll be that why do
you think they're gonna excuse that they
didn't four years ago the Republican
voters on the right wing aren't going to
forgive people who go back on what
they're what they're saying now in their
primary and that's why the Democrats are
loving this they're loving watching
their the Republicans destroy themselves
speaking of Democrats what do you see
how do you see Bernie Sanders he too
certainly is on the rather extreme wing
of his party would you turn him a
populist yeah yeah for sure I'm in a
year ago nobody thought he had a chance
and he did well in Iowa but I was an
extremely unusual state only three
thousand voters were there Clinton by
the way got more voters and all the
Republicans in Iowa she's the real
winner of Iowa but the media is sort of
downplaying that because it wasn't quite
up to expectations but Bernie Sanders is
popular in a state with a lot of college
students on the Left win left fringe
he'll probably do well in New Hampshire
which is right next to his home state of
Vermont but he's not going to win the
nomination he's not going to do well in
states in the south where where Clinton
will do well and he
Trump he's got a new york accent and an
American America hasn't voted for any
booth and within a merit with a new york
accent for a long long time so I don't
think Trump or Sanders has any kind of a
chance over again Herman what is your
take on Bernie Sanders how do you hear
his message well I mean for a European
everything he says sounds very normal I
mean if you know my if you say well you
shouldn't pay for your university or you
shouldn't pay for college well then a
German will degree because we don't pay
for college if he says well you have to
have a social security system like
Sweden a Germans would agree because our
system is more or less the same so for
us for Europeans at what he's off
offering is just normal life but I think
that for Americans is very unusual what
he proposes and I think that there is no
chance in him winning the majority
because it would be against the
tradition of the country but when he
talks about breaking up the banks for
example Alan Posner that is pretty much
heading in the direction of populism
isn't it oh definitely and we have a
strange anglo-saxon phenomenon of
electing at or trying to elect
candidates or leaders on the left to a
grumpy old men stuck in the 70s I mean
think of Jeremy Corbyn in Great Britain
the leader of the Labour Party think of
Bernie Sanders who's you know I mean he
his day was the day of sort of post you
know John F Kennedy Democratic policy
and I don't know what it was about it is
it's really people wishing that we were
back in the welfare state to the 70s in
a way Mr Sanders is just as backward
looking as mr. Trump who wants America
somehow to be you know Reagan's America
and this isn't coming back coming back
to the banks I mean splitting up the
bank for example was the suggestion of a
commission by that the EU Commission had
on regulating European banks it's not
something completely outlandish it's
something that's very difficult to
somehow get into real politics because
the lobbyists of the banks are very very
strong of course but it is nothing you
cannot discuss about let's take
another look at Alan Posner's contention
in his opening statement that American
populism is fun let's remind ourselves
just how much fun Donald Trump's
messages Donald Trump speeches are often
over the top he rails against the
political elite or Mexican immigrants
they're bringing drugs they're bringing
crime they're rapists comp tries to
polarize voters for example the haves
against the have-nots the hatred the
hatred and what it is is establishment
because I'm not taking anybody's money I
don't want their money they don't
control me I'm doing what's right for
you and he seems to believe that voters
will let him get away with just about
anything where I could stand in the
middle of Fifth Avenue and shoot
somebody and I wouldn't lose any voters
okay it's like incredible how long will
the Trump bandwagon continue to roll
Erik Kirschbaum if I listen to that it's
a lot less about fun than about fear who
are the voters that Donald Trump is
trying to appeal to well he does appeal
to the undereducated unported people who
have lost people are on the fringes
people who are losing out redneck see he
really appeals to to that element of
white America that feels like they
they're not represented by anybody and
he's really struck a chord with them and
but as I mentioned before these people
don't usually vote in the election so
they might he might do well in opinion
polls but whether that Trent translates
into votes remains to be seen Iowa
showed it wasn't it could happen right
down the line Ellen Posner would you say
Sanders is targeting a similar group uh
no sign is targeting I think better
educated Americans also mostly white
middle class but people like students
for instance who when they finish
college have thirty five thousand
dollars student loan that they have to
repay are no chance of getting a job
people like sort of you know the upper
upper excellence of middle-class society
but also white and so new haven't seen
an improvement in their living
conditions and were angry at this so
it's two different facets of
middle-class America middle to lower
class America which don't seem to have
profited from the Economic Forum the
economic surge in the Obama years so
it's about inequality or we care how
much yes of course I and America is
extremely in equal for example the
normal earners their real wages haven't
been risen since the 70s that's and
paralleled in the whole of the Western
world so all the growth and for the last
40 years went to the top fringes of
society and of course that's something
people rebel against and then the old
white men vote for Trump and the yang
Whiteman wait for a vote for sanders but
it's the same sentiment but they somehow
lose out so in other words you might say
Bernie Sanders is channeling Occupy Wall
Street and Donald Trump is channeling in
the tea party yeah no yeah i mean Trump
is no tea party he's just representing
the losers Erik Kirschbaum what role to
the media play in all of this they have
as you said been having a field day are
they also actually driving populism
forward in a way they do I mean they put
a spotlight on these people that Bernie
Sanders probably gonna be where he is
without the media coverage he's gotten
and um I think that's one of the bigger
stories of the last year that he's been
able to come so far against such a such
a big organization that Clinton has the
media do play a play a role in the whole
Iowa coverage of Iowa you know you
wonder in clinton one and why is she
being treated like the loser of of iowa
Ellen Posner for some time now the
political science community has been
documenting the rise of polarization in
the u.s. it produced an absolute bloke
blockade in government in the course of
the Obama presidency most of his major
initiatives were passed with few or no
Republican votes whatsoever is that
itself now feeding the kind of mistrust
in government that we're seeing yeah
definitely and this
actually this is actually this is a it's
a structural problem I think something
like eighty or two ninety percent of the
seats in Congress are safe seats
Republican or Democrat so the only real
contest is between the Democratic
nominees themselves in the primaries and
there the person who is more radical
tends to win among the party faithful
the rabble-rousers so this is what
happens if you had a redrawing of
congressional districts which meant that
these people had to come up against
someone from the other party they would
automatically tone down the rhetoric and
that would that would do America world
of good that's what needs to happen
that's the gerrymandering phenomenon
what about the money phenomenon Arica
herman what role is that playing in in
the rise of these extreme and populist
oriented candidates well i think the
money of course is an extreme problem
especially of course Wall Street it pays
literally billions of dollars for the
election campaigns and of course that's
why they have such a strong Lobby in
Congress but I think that many of these
tea party Republicans who want seats
didn't have this much money and it is a
way of the people of the voters
rebelling against the power of the elite
against the lobbyists but they vote for
those candidates who do not have much
money but who are very radical in a way
you know if you do not have much money
you must be radical to have the media
coverage that you cannot pay for so in
the money does not go to the tea party
representatives but the money it feeds
on the anger that then again feeds this
or makes these radicals possible in
Congress interestingly enough Erik
Kirschbaum you could say that
polarization is now coming home to roost
within the parties we're seeing it
divide arising within each of the two
political parties what's that about I
mean you can't miss the polarization in
America it's been going on for years and
getting worse all the time one would
hope that they'd get over with it and
you can start working together again but
after the last two elections it just
seemed to get worse
the polarization especially on the
Conservative Party and especially the
Republicans a lot of people think
they're close to imploding they just
can't seem to get their act together I
mean I'm not sure that the Republic rats
are that fractured as the Republicans
are but i think it's it's a scary thing
to think what could happen the
Republican Party if they just can't get
their act together and and and we're
seeing this this this primary election
the Republicans are just just totally
fighting they're totally squabbling and
and four years ago it looks like a tea
party compare or a picnic compared to
what we're seeing this time and I just
can imagine the Democrats are gonna be
showing these film clips and Republicans
bashing each other in October and
November it's they're just shooting
themselves in the foot do you not think
that the candidate like a cruise like a
Rubio could reunite the Republican Party
going into the general election Cruz is
pretty far on the right and he's a tea
party and I think he's gonna he will
really galvanize the Democrat voters and
a lot of Republicans will probably
middle the road Republicans will vote
for the Democrats I mean most of the
u.s. presidential elections have been
one in the middle Obama campaigned on
the left but he became a very centrist
president and so was Bill Clinton before
that so Cruz's president is also very
very hard to imagine if there's another
candidate like Jeb Bush if he gets his
act together in New Hampshire I mean a
year ago everybody thought Jeb Bush was
gonna be the candidate and I know he's
far out of it now but maybe he'll he has
the money and if he can turn it around
and no Hampshire maybe he'd be a
candidate that a lot of Republicans
could rally around that they're hungry
to win obviously but they just seemed to
be imploding and falling apart Alan
Posner I'd like to come back to this
whole issue of the fear and mistrust and
its impact on the on the political
system in general Erik Kirschbaum was
saying that the Republican Party is in
dire straits he mentioned the
possibility even of implosion do you
think that there is a serious threat
here to the system as a whole no i don't
i mean the threat is there to America
because America is in is seemed to be
under Obama in decline there's you know
people's oxide is this there's no people
who have job security there's a question
of the rise of China there's the
question of America's not being able to
impose any kind of order in the Middle
East and and and it seems to be too many
Americans that this is not the country
they bought into and it reminds me a bit
of the of the time after Jimmy Carter
when Jimmy Carter's president said we
have a malaise in the country and he
talked about decline and then came
Ronald Reagan and say it's morning in
America I'm going to make America great
again that phrase that Donald Trump has
borrowed by the way and that's what
America's want Americans want to see
they want to see their country great
again and it's the question can America
do it I think they can they're the
biggest economy in the world they have
immense resources the most attractive
but you need a leader who points who
accentuates the positive as they say in
the song and that wasn't Obama and find
the leader who can tap into this into
this need and you will have a great
president speaking of leaders
interestingly enough the yearning for a
strong leader together with
anti-immigrant sentiment is one factor
that seems to unite both European and
American populism let's take a look
Hungarian Prime Minister Viktor Orban
speaks out against migrants he's put up
border fences to keep them out and he's
convinced that there's a link between
immigration and terrorism
in Germany a leader of the
anti-immigrant afd party recently said
the police should be able to use
firearms against illegal migrants the
German interior ministry said that will
never happen in France marine lepen
leader of the right-wing National Front
party has called the EU an impotent
empire that is robbed France blind she
wants France to stop using the euro
currency European populist and Donald
Trump have one thing in common they all
admire russian president latina Putin
Putin has promised to make Russia a
player on the world stage once again in
Europe populists candidates are becoming
increasingly popular will that happen in
the US as well mccammon do you think
we're seeing a similar phenomenon on
both sides of the Atlantic in the rise
of extremist sentiments in that
anti-immigrant bashing that we saw there
and perhaps also in this yearning for
someone who just takes a strong hand to
things yeah I think there are four
things that are similar first this fear
of immigrants then this idea that you
have to have a strong leader then this
idea that the media are always just
telling lies and then that it basically
rests on this social fear that the
people might lose out usually even in
Germany its losers who vote for the
populace are those fearing to lose
sometimes they are still quite well-off
but they have the appear that their
children might not be successful or
something like that so there are
similarities how much does that have to
do with the sense perhaps in the US as
well as in Europe that somehow our
economic system is on the wane and for
instance China on the rise well I think
that's not the point because I mean I'm
not I do not agree with Allen frozen
about the US and that Obama has become
weak or has been economically not
successful that no no no it was a there
were many new jobs created in the US
that's not the problem
but these jobs are not well paid that's
the problem so what you would need in
the u.s. is to have higher taxes for the
rich but that exactly is not possible
because you have the Republicans in the
Congress would never ever agree and so
it's more about social inequality it's
not about growth you have growth but
people just do not profit let me ask all
of you to please come back to our title
we asked in the second part of the title
how dangerous is populism what do you
think Erik Kirschbaum both in the US and
here to what degree is this a true
threat to the kind of democracy that we
take for granted I don't think it's a
threat i think it's part of the
political spectrum and i think it's
something that's the more it's talked
about the more the more you see what
kind of people these are on the fringes
and the the u.s. election right now is
the primary season I mean that's when
these things kind of get to discussed
and talked about and at the end of the
day there's going to be a
middle-of-the-road candidate for sure
from both parties you suggested in your
opening statement Alan that the threat
is not particularly great in the US but
is here dangerous yeah dangerous because
unlike in America populist are already
in power here and as we saw in the clip
they could be in power and run of EO in
in France before long and these
populists seeeeee they can implement
their policies and they're tearing
Europe apart they're tearing the fabric
of Europe apart and this is why it's so
incredibly dangerous and they're
destroying democracy and so so Europe
need not point a finger at Donald Trump
because he's just entertainment Europe
needs to really really its own position
on populism these people are real and
they're destroying Europe and the
destroying democracy with it but you
know if I remember back to the 90s we
had a very heated discussion here in
Germany about the rise of a party called
the Republicans that was also quite
quite extreme right it's gone it's
vanished yeah but we didn't have well it
didn't have a populace in power in
Hungary populace in power and Poland a
populist knocking on the door of the eel
is a palace and you know and the AFD is
is much cleverer than the Republicans
ever were so it is
different situation oh we cammin
populism a danger in the US and a danger
in Europe yeah in Europe it's a danger
of all the reasons I'm said but I think
I do not agree that there is no danger
for a popular of populism in the yes i
think that the probable outcome will be
that you have a democratic president
called Hillary Clinton but that you will
let you will not be able to rule or to
do anything because she will have a
congress that's not working because all
the trumps of the country or the tea
party or all those idiots will be
sitting having the majority in the
Congress and we'll just prevent any
sensible action being taken I just agree
that there because Obama wasn't able to
do that Obama wasn't able to get the
deals done with the opposition with the
Republicans but Bill Clinton did Bill
Clinton had a very successful presidency
because there was a bit different yeah
but they weren't they weren't as extreme
but he still had a he was a minority
president for six of his eight years and
he got a lot of things done and I think
Hillary Clinton will be more successful
than Obama in working with a congress
controlled by the Republicans thank you
very much thanks to all of you for being
with us today and thanks to all of you
out there for tuning in see you soon and
please follow our campaign hashtag what
America and please do check out our
campaign hashtag what America my
colleagues in Washington are traveling
around the country asking Americans what
America they want check us out hashtag
what America